Before we start talking about robotic vision,
it’s going to be very useful just to revisit
some fundamentals of robots, and in particular,
definitions of what a robot is.
For those of you who participated in the first
online course, we presented this definition
of what a robot is: It’s a goal-oriented
machine that can sense, plan and act. And
the important keywords are highlighted here
in red.
A more casual definition that we introduced
for a robot is that it’s a machine that
can move—either itself or perhaps its hand—from
place A to place B. So we might move its hand
to pick up an object at place A, and put it
down at place B; or it might move its entire
body. It might move along a corridor from
place A in the corridor to place B in the
corridor.
Let’s now look at some of the keywords in
the first, more detailed definition, and one
of the key concepts is sensing.
A robot fundamentally is a machine that can
sense its environment. The sorts of things
that it might want to sense is: where is the
object that it needs to manipulate—where
is the thing that it needs to pick up. Another
thing that it might want to sense is where
is the robot itself. A mobile robot in a corridor
situation; whereabouts in the corridor is
the robot? This is the classical ‘where
am I?’ problem of mobile robotics.
Another thing a robot needs to do is to plan.
So from its sensors it knows where it is;
it knows where the things that it needs to
work with are; it has got a goal, a thing
that it wants to achieve. So it makes a plan
of where to move from its current state to
its goal state.
And the final part of the process is to carry
out some action. Given that I’ve got a plan,
now I have to carry out the step of the plan.
I grab the object or I move myself from place
A to place B.